We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a voicemail inquiring about
exactly the scenario that I outlined earlier
for Election Day and election week.
Take a listen to this.
David Démarche from China here.
I'm thinking the most likely scenario on election
night is that Trump will declare victory because
most Republicans will vote in person.
And most of their votes will have been carried
by them.
By that point in thinking, Democrats will
have their votes counted in basis not weeks
after.
And Trump would call fraud potentially leading
to some violence.
How how can you even prepare for something
like that?
So listen, let me get to the preparation in
a second.
But yes, what Tomas is describing here is
the Red Mirage hypothesis.
The Red Mirage hypothesis will be, since we
know that we're going to have so so the people
planning to vote in person are mostly Trump
people.
And the people planning to vote absentee are
mostly Biden people.
Now, the the exact proportions will determine
whether this happens.
But it is a completely plausible scenario
that Trump seems to eke out some victory on
election night, claims victory, and then as
absentee ballots continue to be counted.
I don't think it will take weeks, but it certainly
could take five days.
The lead for Trump shrinks, shrinks, shrinks,
until ultimately Joe Biden takes an electoral
lead.
And you are completely correct, Tomas, that
that is a scenario ripe for real world violence.
And so the question about how to be prepared
for it is twofold.
First of all, police departments and national
law enforcement, federal law enforcement need
to take seriously the possibility of not protests
of overwhelmingly unarmed individuals, but
angry weaponized Trump ists with firearms
taking to the streets.
That's a law enforcement question.
The political question is we know because
Trump has said that they're going to do this
and people around him have said they've got
an army of lawyers ready to go.
We know that if this scenario happens, if
Trump seems to be ahead on election night
with a lot of absentee ballots still to be
counted immediately, they are going to file
lawsuits to try to stop the absentee ballots
from being counted.
They are going to try to say they've got to
be in by it by midnight Election Day or they've
got to be in by the next day.
But you can't just keep counting absentee
ballots.
Whether they will get away with it, I don't
know.
But Democrats and Joe Biden's campaign need
to have a proactive plan for how they are
going to fight that in court.
Now, unfortunately, when Trump brags he's
put in place, is it 200 something, 300 judges
at this point?
It may be some of those judges who end up
deciding in some states, do the absentee ballots
continue to be counted or not?
So it is a very serious scenario.
And I don't know if Democrats are going to
be prepared if history is an indicator.
Democrats may well not be prepared for that.
And that's very, very scary.
On the bonus show today, we are going to talk
about the pandemic remaining the top issue
for voters going into November and what effect
that is likely to have depending on what happens
with the virus in the next eight weeks.
We're also going to talk about calls to end
open carry of firearms, period, as an institution.
And lastly, Jacob Blake's father is now receiving
death threats.
Jacob Blake, of course.
Is the young man who is now paralyzed after
being shot in Kenosha, Wisconsin, and now
his father is the one receiving death threats.
It's unconscionable.
And we will talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show.
Become a member, get instant access at join
Pacman Icon.